[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اعلنت حركه حماس مسؤوليتها عن
عمليه اطلاق النار في تل ابيب اقلت انها
جاءت ردا على جرائم الاحتلال وتوعدت بمزيد
من الضربات المجيعه للاحتلال وقالت هيئه
البث الاسرائيلي ان خمسه اسرائيليين
اصيبوا بينهم اثنان في حاله خطره في عمليه
اطلاق النار وسط تل ابيب واضافت ان وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي امر بهدم منزل منفذ
عمليه تل ابيب وقالت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه ان رئيس الحكومه بنيام نتانياهو
قرر الاستمرار في زيارته الايطاليه وامر
بتعزيز القوات الامنيه في الميدان
هذا وافاد مراسل الجزيره ان قوات كبيره من
جيش الاحتلال اقتحمت منزل منفذ عمليه
اطلاق النار في تل ابيب في قريه علين غرب
رام الله
وتاتي عمليه تل ابيب بعد ساعات من اقتحام
قوه اسرائيليه خاصه بلده جبع جنوب جنين
وقتلها ثلاثه فلسطينيين ينتمون لسرايا
القدس
وزير الدفاع الامريكي عن قلقه العميق زائم
وصفه بالتطور الخطير الذي تحرزه ايران في
مجال تخصيب اليورانيوم من جانبه قال وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي له يجب الاستعداد
للتحرك على كل الصعود لمنع ايران من
امتلاك سلاح
في المقابل دعا ممثل ايران لدى الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الدول الغربيه الى
التخلي عما سماه سيناريو رابح خاسر وتغيير
موقفها تجاه ايران
في هجوم صاروخي وجوي متزامن هو الاوسع منذ
اسابيع استهدفت القوات الروسيه مناطق
واسعه في اوكرانيا فجر امس بينها
في الغرب واوديس في الجنوب اضافتان
العاصمه وقالت موسكو ان ضرباتها تاتي ردا
على الهجمات في مقاطعه الروسيه الاسبوع
الماضي
بجانبه وصف مدير الاستخبارات المركزيه
الاشهر المقبله بالحاسمه في ساحه المعركه
باوكرانيا وفي هذه الاثناء قالت المتحدثه
باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ان خطط
بولندا لبناء مركز تدريب عسكري ميداني في
غرب اوكرانيا ستجعلها طرفا في النزاع
واضافت ان هذا الامر يورط هولندا صدر في
تونس المرسوم الرئاسي القاضي بحل المجالس
البلديه وكان الرئيس قيس سعيد اعلن
اعتزامه حل هذه المجالس
واستبدالها بمجال مؤقته حتى موعد
الانتخابات المقبله وقال المناسق العام
لائتلاف صمود ان القرار يدل على عدم
اعتراف السلطه بالمشروعيه الشعبيه من
جهتها دعت منظمه انا يقظ الرقابيه المجالس
البلديه الى الطعن على قرار الرئيس امام
المحكمه الاداريه
من جهته قال او قالت مساعده وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي للشؤون الشرق الادنى ان الرئيس
التونسيه اخذ البلاد الى مسار بعيد جدا عن
المسار الديمقراطيه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]